VACCINATION STATUS.
ANTHONY?
>> THANK YOU.
>>> WHITE HOUSE SENIOR ADVISER
FOR THE COVID RESPONSE TEAM ANDY
SLAVITT JOINS US NOW.
GOOD MORNING.
AS WE JUST HEARD FROM WEIJA,
WE'VE GOT 22% IN OUR POLL SAYING
THEY WILL NOT GET THE VACCINE.
ANOTHER 18% SAYING MAYBE THEY
WON'T.
HOW DO YOU ADDRESS THAT?
>> WELL, GOOD MORNING.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME ON.
LOOK, AMERICANS HAVE AN
IMPORTANT DECISION TO MAKE, AND
I THINK AS AMERICANS DO THEIR
HOMEWORK THEY'RE GOING TO
REALIZE THAT IT'S REALLY SMART
FOR THEM TO DO.
THEY REALLY HAVE TO DO THAT
HOMEWORK THEMSELVES.
IF THEY LOOK AT THE OVER 130
MILLION AMERICANS THAT HAVE BEEN
VACCINATED, THEY LOOK AT HOW
MUCH SAFER THEY ARE, THE THINGS
THAT THEY CAN DO NOW, THEY
COMPARE THAT TO THE INCREDIBLY
MODEST IF ALMOST NONEXISTENT
RISK OF TAKING A VACCINE, I
THINK THAT THAT'S WHERE THEY'LL
END UP.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS LOOK AT
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN INDIA, EVEN
MICHIGAN.
IF YOU'RE A YOUNGER PERSON, SEE
WHAT THE RISK IS FROM COVID.
I THINK PEOPLE WILL DO THEIR
HOMEWORK.
I ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO TALK TO
THEIR DOCTORS.
TALK TO PEOPLE YOU TRUST.
TALK TO YOUR PHARMACISTS.
DON'T LISTEN TO POLITICIANS.
DON'T LISTEN TO SENATORS.
DON'T LISTEN TO ME.
TALK TO THE PEOPLE IN YOUR LIFE
I THINK MOST PEOPLE END UP
MAKING THE DECISION.
>> ARE YOU WORRIED -- 51% OF
REPUBLICANS DON'T WANT TO GET
THE VACCINE.
COULD THIS ESCALATE AS A
PRINCIPLE PROBLEM?
>> WE'RE GOING TO TRY TO PREVENT
THAT.
WE DON'T THINK IN THOSE TERMS.
WE THINK THAT PEOPLE WANT TO BE
INFORMED, THEY WANT TO BE
EDUCATED.
SOME PEOPLE HAVE QUESTIONS.
SOME PEOPLE ARE YOUNGER AND
DON'T FEEL AS MUCH OF A THREAT
AS PEOPLE WHO ARE OLDER, SO THEY
NEED IT TO BE MORE CONVENIENT.
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE IN COMMUNITIES WHO WE
CALL THE COMMUNITY CORE WHO ARE
BASICALLY PREPARED TO ANSWER
PEOPLE'S QUESTIONS.
WE TALKED TO DOCTORS AND
SCIENTISTS AND -- AND THE
MEDICAL ADVICE THAT PEOPLE GET.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO ENCOURAGE
THEM MORE THAN NOT TO TAKE THE
VACCINE.
SO I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE STEP
BY STEP.
I DON'T THINK IT'S GOING TO BE
AS FAST AS IT HAS BEEN OVER THE
FIRST 100 DAYS OR SO.
I THINK WE'LL GET THERE.
>> TO WHAT DEGREE DO YOU THINK
VACCINE HESITANCY WILL DELAY A
RETURN TO SOME FIND OF NORMALCY?
>> YOU KNOW, I THINK THERE'S A
COMMUNITY-BY-COMMUNITY ANSWER
THERE.
IF WE HAVE COMMUNITIES IN THE
COUNTRY WHERE WE HAVE VERY HIGH
DEGREES OF VACCINATIONS, I THINK
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE VERY MUCH A
2019-TYPE OF A LIFE.
IF WE HAVE COMMUNITIES IN THE
COUNTRY WHERE MAYBE ONLY HALF OF
THE PEOPLE GET VACCINATED, THEN
THEY'RE GOING TO BE AT SERIOUS
RISK FOR THESE VARIANTS COMING
IN, AND HAVING HAPPENED WHAT'S
HAPPENED IN MICHIGAN RECENTLY.
THANKFULLY, THEY'RE RECOVERING
-- BEGINNING TO RECOVER FROM
THAT.
BUT THE COMMUNITIES THAT DON'T
HAVE HIGH DEGREES OF VACCINATION
ARE GOING TO BE A LITTLE MORE
JEOPARDY.
>> THE JOHNSON & JOHNSON VACCINE
HAS NOW BEEN DEEMED SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE FOR THE VAST MAJORITY
OF PEOPLE.
BUT IT SEEMS TO HAVE BEEN
TAINTED IN SOME PEOPLE'S MINDS
THAT IT'S KIND OF EFFECTIVELY A
SECOND-CLASS VACCINE.
ARE YOU CONCERNED THAT ITS
REPUTATION HAS EFFECTIVELY BEEN
DAMAGED?
>> I DON'T THINK PEOPLE SHOULD
LOOK AT IT THAT WAY.
I THINK THE FIRST CONCLUSION
PEOPLE SHOULD TAKE AWAY IS OUR
DRUG SAFETY SYSTEM IS WORKING
GREAT.
THAT MEANS THAT IF THERE IS EVEN
THE SLIGHTEST CONCERN OR THE
SLIGHTEST ISSUE, WE'LL KNOW
ABOUT IT.
THE FDA WILL TAKE ACTION ON IT.
THEY'LL STUDY IT.
AND THEY'LL COME BACK AND MAKE
THE RIGHT RECOMMENDATIONS.
THERE'S NO WAY THE FDA WOULD
RECOMMEND AND THE CDC WOULD
ALLOW THIS DRUG TO BE PUT IN
PEOPLE'S ARMS IF PEOPLE WEREN'T
VERY COMFORTABLE WITH IT.
SO PEOPLE JUST DO THEIR
HOMEWORK.
SOME WILL PREFER A SINGLE-DOSE
VACCINE, JOHNSON & JOHNSON, AN
OUTSTANDING VACCINE.
SOME PREFER PFIZER AND MODERNA.
AND WE'RE IN A FORTUNATE
POSITION WHERE WE HAVE THREE
HIGHLY EFFECTIVE VACCINES, AND
PEOPLE I THINK HAVE SOME
OPTIONS.
BUT NO, I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE
WILL CONTINUE TO WANT TO TAKE
THE JOHNSON & JOHNSON VACCINE.
>> YEAH.
DR. ASHISH JAH, WITH US IN THIS
BROADCAST, SAID HE CONSIDERS IT